Why don't we try an example using this rational zero theorem? Let's say we have
this function. f of x equals 4 x squared minus 4 x plus 1. Now, I know that,
based on the rational zero theorem, any rational zero of this polynomial must
be a factor of 1 divided by a factor of 4. Since 1 is the constant term in the
expression, and 4 is the leading coefficient. Well, 1 has factors of just 1 and
negative 1. And four has factors of 1 and 4, and also their negatives. And also
2 and negative 2. Can you tell me then, what the possible ratios of factors of
1, or of factors of 4 are? These are the possible rational zeros that the
rational zero theorem says that this function can have. I'll give you one more
hint. There are six different fractions that we should get. As always, please
separate these answers by commas.